STUDENTS, BUT WE DID NOT HEAR
BACK.
SO JOINING ME NOW PARENT FROM
NEW YORK CITY SCHOOLS DISTRICT
BRIAN ROBINSON THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING ME TONIGHT.
>> ABSOLUTELY THANKS FOR HAVING
ME.
ONE THING THAT I WAS FASCINATED
WITH I THINK IT IS KIND OF SAD
AS I'M INTERVIEWING THIS ONE
PARENT.
I'M TRYING TO TALK TO OTHER
PARENTS THEY'RE VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS NOT ANTI-IMMIGRANT
THEY LOVE KIDS AND UNDERSTAND
THE STRAIN.
THEY WERE AFRAID TO COME ON CRAM
WITH ME BECAUSE THEY FELT LIKE
THEY WOULD BE TARGETED.
TIEWK MESS ABOUT THAT.
>> THAT JUST SPEAKS TO CULTURE
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY AND A LOT
OF HYPERBLUE STATES CITIES, I
MEAN, PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO TALK
PARENTS ARE AFRAID TO TALK, AND
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
REALITY.
IT IS KIND OF LIKE BEING STUCK
IN MATRIX WITH A REALITY AND
NOBODY ACCOUNTS TO TALK ABOUT IT
AND GO WITH APPEARANCES AND ONLY
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IS IDEALISTIC
THERE'S ONE PROBLEM AFTER
ANOTHER THERE'S LATEST STATE OF
EMERGENCY HERE IN NEW YORK
AND --
IT'S A REAL ISSUE IF WE THINK
LOGICALLY SCHOOLS HAVE A LIMITED
INFRASTRUCTURE.
RIGHT?
WE WORK HARD TO PUT OUR KIDS
INTO THESE SCHOOLS.
WE PAID TAXES.
NOW, WE HAVE COMPASSION, BUT WE
CAN'T LET THE ENTIRE SHIP SINK
BECAUSE OUR COMPASSION IS
UNLIMITED BECAUSE OUR RESOURCES
ARE NOT --
>> WHY DID THE ELECTORATE
LEADERS IN NEW YORK CITY AND NEW
YORK STATE SAY WE'RE A SANCTUARY
AND WHEN PEOPLE COME HERE
THEY'RE NOT PREPARED TO MEET THE
--
THAT THEY NEVER THINK THAT THE
PEOPLE WERE GOING TO COME TO NEW
YORK CITY BECAUSE DEFINITELY NOT
PREPARED.
FRANKLY WE CAN'T BACK IT UP.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH
MODERN DAY DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
EVERYTHING IS SKIN DEEP.
SO YOU SAY OH WE'RE A SANCTUARY
CITY THAT SOUNDS BEAUTIFUL WE
ARE --
YOU KNOW SELF-RIGHTEOUS HIGH WE
HAVE HIGHER MORAL REGARD FOR
HUMANITY NOT WHEN PUSH COMES TO
SHOVE SO HERE WE ARE STATE OF
EMERGENCY WE DONGT HAVE THE
CAPACITY HOMELESS SHELTERS AND
ALREADY MAXED OUT.
AND NOW WE HAVE THIS INFLUX.
>> HOW IS THIS IMPACTING THES
AMERICAN KIDS THAT ARE IN THE
CLASSROOM TODAY?
>> DEPENDS ON THE SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW, IT'S STARTING TO
OVERFLOW FROM ONE SCHOOL TO THES
OTHER.
I'VE SPOKEN TO PARENTS WHO HAVE
STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS.
WHERE IT'S GOTTEN OUT OF CONTROL
AND QUALITY IS DIMINISHING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
CAPACITY.
OTHER SCHOOLS THEY DON'T KNOW
WHEN IT'S GOING HAPPEN OR IF
IT'S GOING HAPPEN WHETHER IT'S
GOING LEAK OVER OR NOT SO WE'LL
SEE.
BUT ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS THIS
IS A PROBLEM THAT THERE'S NO
SOLUTION TO AS FAR AS THE MAYOR
GOES, GOVERNMENT HERE GOES.
WE HAVE TO TAKE MORE DESEES I
DECISIVE ACTION SAD STATE TO SEE
WE'LL SEE WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
KIDS EDUCATION.
WE'RE PRAYING FOR PARENTS HERE
AND HOPEFULLY THAT LEADERS WAKE
UP.
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
TO STUDIO.